today's Tuesday January sixth welcome to
gamespot news I'm your host Chris waters
here to catch you up on the latest from
the consumer electronics show in las
vegas which kicks off today and from the
wide world of video games which kicked
off like a few decades ago let's get to
it you know CES is underway when you
start seeing freaky expensive versions
of gaming tech that you will probably
never own say h-e-l-l-o to the L Y and X
controller from Mad Catz you can take it
apart C and put it back together to
better play games on various mobile
devices and then fold it up into a
little bundle when you're done there's a
keyboard and a microphone and a $300
price tag and now for my obligatory it
looks like joke it looks like some Robo
piranhas skeletonized a dualshock 4
share yours in the comments below you
know that innovative tech is going to be
around for a while when more and more
versions of it start popping up enter
the OS VR an open-source virtual reality
headset from razor aiming to support a
variety of operating systems including
windows android and linux as well as a
bunch of game engines device plugins and
middleware the osv are also plans to
support software designed for the oculus
dk2 it's got to 5.5 inch displays a 100
degree field of view and an
accelerometer gyroscope and compass all
in service of a 1080 x 1920 display for
announced price of two hundred dollars
you know it's early in the year when the
biggest actual game news is just DLC for
games that came out last year first up
the g-shock car pack for Forza horizon 2
brings five new cars that today's game
spot news producer Andy Baumann will
almost certainly by four five dollars
secondly Ubisoft is delivering their
first make good for Assassin's Creed
unity troubled launch by serving up dead
Kings for free a fully fledged
single-player campaign that includes a
ridiculously named guillotine gun and
finally destiny players are getting some
kind of belated legendary holiday gift
this week See Mom January's not too late
to send things so there you know some
folks are going to be making that crazy
ebay money when Nintendo releases
limited-edition schwag that you
actually by select club nintendo
customers across europe are being
offered the chance to buy a special new
Nintendo 3ds called the Ambassador
edition it's got a special faceplate and
the new see stick and ZL and Zr buttons
how do you get it Nintendo basically
said don't call us we'll call you and as
for the Majora's Mask 3d limited edition
that comes with a skull kid' collectible
figurine pretty much all sold out
already people like Zelda I guess who
knew that's it for today hooray now you
can go on your way with something to say
for anyone in your way he wants to talk
about video games nailed it